Alice:杨老板你还要录一期吗
Alice: Jake, are you going to record another episode?
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:看这一期怎么样
Jake: Let's see how this episode goes.
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Jake:你问我打算我很难回答你
Jake: It's hard for me to answer your plans.
Alice:确实
Alice: True.
Lucia:你问我打算我很难回答你
Lucia: It's hard for me to answer your plans.
Alice:懂了懂了
Alice: Got it, got it.
Jake:哈哈哈你问我
Jake: Hahaha, you ask me.
Jake:下一步有什么打算
Jake: What's the next step?
Alice:来这里我突然发现我其实并不P
Alice: Coming here, I suddenly realized I'm not really P.
Lucia:其实我也觉得
Lucia: Actually, I feel the same.
Alice:其实我每天我感觉每天我都在想事情
Alice: Actually, every day I feel like I'm always thinking.
Alice:脑子里比较急
Alice: My mind is kind of anxious.
Alice:呀对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Lucia:对不起对不起
Lucia: Sorry, sorry.
Alice:我 我草
Alice: I, I damn...
Jake:哎哟哟
Jake: Oh dear.
Alice:我
Alice: I...
Lucia:我太重了
Lucia: I'm too heavy.
Alice:没事它这个石子不是那啥 的
Alice: It's okay, the stone isn't that... you know.
Jake:没事没事没有对对对石子
Jake: It's okay, it's okay, no, no, it's the stone.
Jake:石头的问题
Jake: It's the stone's problem.
Jake:不是您的不是您的问题
Jake: It's not your fault, not your fault.
Lucia:换个凳子
Lucia: Let's change the stool.
Alice:这晚上坐着还有点冰屁股呢
Alice: Sitting here at night is kind of cold on the butt.
Lucia:是晚上还挺冷的
Lucia: Yeah, it's quite cold at night.
Jake:晚上挺冷的 这几天
Jake: It's pretty cold at night, these days.
Lucia:我都
Lucia: I even...
Jake:这一周竟然都没有下雨
Jake: It hasn't rained at all this week.
Jake:有点意思
Jake: Interesting.
Alice:挺好
Alice: Nice.
Jake:北京是这样吗
Jake: Is it like this in Beijing?
Alice:北京下雨本来就不不多
Alice: It doesn't rain much in Beijing.
Lucia:不太多
Lucia: Not too much.
Jake:噢 噢  噢噢
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Alice:嗯但是这几天天气都很好
Alice: Yeah, but the weather has been great these days.
Jake:对对
Jake: Right, right.
Alice:对空气还很好
Alice: And the air is really good too.
Lucia:所以其实
Lucia: So actually...
Alice:这就不太
Alice: It's not really...
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:假北京
Jake: Fake Beijing.
Lucia:所以我们其实应该多录点户外的
Lucia: So we should actually record more outdoor stuff.
Alice:户外也差不多可以了
Alice: Outdoor is pretty much fine too.
Lucia:趁着天气好
Lucia: While the weather is good.
Jake:对已经加了好几场了 天很少
Jake: Right, we've already added several sessions. The weather is rare.
Jake:主要是我不想跑
Jake: Mainly, I don't want to run.
Lucia:加了好几场去超市的吧
Lucia: We've added several trips to the supermarket, right?
Jake:对还有别的户外
Jake: Yeah, and other outdoor activities.
Jake:确实没有
Jake: Truly, there aren't any.
Jake:那那打的就是抓娃娃
Jake: So, the thing is catching dolls.
Jake:那确实很贵对
Jake: That indeed is very expensive, right.
Alice:啊是
Alice: Ah, yes.
Lucia:所以像抓娃娃那种说介绍有什么用啊
Lucia:好奇一下
Jake:嗯
Jake: Uh-huh.
Lucia:呃我又不在你们竞争对手公司是吧
Lucia: Uh, I'm not with your competitor company, right?
Lucia:可以放心的给我透露一点
Lucia: So you can safely tell me a bit.
Jake:没关系这东西都开源了
Jake: It's okay, this stuff is all open-source.
Jake:过两个月啥也没
Jake: In a couple of months, it'll be nothing.
Jake:对嗯我不知道
Jake: Yeah, uh, I don't know.
Jake:不是不是我大概知道
Jake: No, no, I kind of know.
Jake:是说里边他们会抓一个娃娃对吧
Jake: Inside, they will catch a doll, right?
Jake:最后他不是以前不是抓那个娃娃吗
Jake: In the end, it wasn't like they used to catch that doll?
Jake:然后那个娃娃可能就能在某一个时间
Jake: Then that doll might be at a certain time.
Jake:有一个链接
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:是娃娃岛来的呀
Jake: It's from Doll Island.
Jake:然后就可以倒到那个时间点去
Jake: Then you can go back to that point in time.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia:那如果没抓上呢
Lucia: What if it doesn't catch?
Jake:没抓上没抓上我就会有别的解释
Jake: If it doesn't catch, I'll have another explanation.
Alice:比如说
Alice: Like what?
Jake:不知道啊现在不是我不知道
Jake: I don't know, I don't know right now.
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my goodness.
Lucia:好有意思啊
Lucia: This is so interesting.
Lucia:这是这是正常的么
Lucia: Is this normal?
Jake:总会
Jake: It always is.
Lucia:这真是
Lucia: This really is...
Lucia:这是应该的
Lucia: This is how it should be.
Alice:这是这是可以的
Alice: This is, this is okay.
Alice:这竟然是可以的
Alice: This is actually okay.
Alice:给了一个很真诚但是感觉不太真诚回答
Alice: You gave a very sincere but not-so-sincere answer.
Jake:就是
Jake: Exactly.
Lucia:他经常说出一些
Lucia: He often says things...
Lucia:我觉得好像是在忽悠我们
Lucia: I feel like he's tricking us.
Lucia:但是这才是真的话
Lucia: But this time it's the truth.
Alice:但是这才是真的话
Alice: But this time it's the truth.
Lucia:我觉得你才应该去玩那个四真两假
Lucia: I think you should play that "Four truths and two lies" game.
Lucia:那个
Lucia: That one.
Alice:对啊
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:噢 噢
Jake: Oh, oh.
Lucia:你就光把你记好的那个大家觉得肯定是编的
Lucia: Just say things that everyone thinks are made up.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Alice:p到如此地步
Alice: To such an extent.
Alice:这是
Alice: This is...
Lucia:这是可以的吗
Lucia: Is this allowed?
Alice:我现在就改换人格
Alice: I'm going to change my personality now.
Jake:做科研嘛
Jake: Doing research...
Jake:就是要探索
Jake: It's all about exploration.
Alice:哈哈我现在就改换人格了
Alice: Haha, I'm changing my personality now.
Alice:脱下我的ENMP面具
Alice: Taking off my ENMP mask.
Jake:你们J很多啊
Jake: You guys have a lot of J's.
Jake:你们这些J人
Jake: You guys are so ridiculous.
Lucia:我真的是p人
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:不知为何我总觉得哪里有点怪怪的
Lucia: I don't know why, but something feels off.
Lucia:我们不会真的在传销组织吧
Lucia: Are we really in some kind of pyramid scheme?
Alice:这是啥呀 露西
Alice:又是 哦 葱
Alice: Oh, it's scallions again.
Jake:来来来
Jake: Come on, come on.
Alice:我今天吃的时候甚至都没吃葱
Alice: I didn't even eat scallions today.
Lucia:不是干吃吗
Lucia: Aren't you supposed to eat it dry?
Alice:披萨卷葱中西合并了
Lucia:所以被吃掉的那些东西他也可以
Lucia: So the stuff that's been eaten, he can also...
Jake:对吃掉的这些东西
Jake: Yeah, the stuff that's eaten...
Jake:他也可以 他也可以 怎么
Jake: He can also, he can also... How?
Jake:可以和
Jake: He can...
Lucia:它就跟娃娃机一个道理吗
Lucia: Is it like a claw machine?
Jake:吃掉的这些东西
Jake: The stuff that's eaten...
Jake:这也不是
Jake: This isn't...
Jake:就是这些
Jake: It's just that...
Jake:可能吃披萨这种活动呢
Jake: Maybe eating pizza like this...
Jake:刚刚我们也没怎么好好录
Jake: We didn't really record it well earlier.
Jake:但是就是说是前一段和后一段
Jake: But the thing is, the beginning and the end...
Jake:中间有个尬舞
Jake: There's a dance break in the middle.
Jake:然后但是
Jake: And then...
Jake:你们可能就是我们现在录的这些东西
Jake: Maybe the things we're recording now...
Jake:然后就就有一个问
Jake: And then there's a question...
Jake:就是
Jake: It's...
Jake:就问AI说我们刚刚可能干一些什么事情
Jake: Asking AI what we might have been doing...
Jake:在一个空余的时间里面
Jake: During a free time period.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:那最后我们那个每个人的行动路线
Alice: So our final action plan...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:会会显示每个人偏好干嘛
Alice: Will show everyone's preferences.
Jake:这个应该很容易
Jake: This should be easy.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia:那会显示每个人偏好干嘛
Lucia: It will show everyone's preferences.
Alice:我偏好洗衣服
Alice: I prefer doing laundry.
Alice:哈哈哈我每天都把油弄在衣服上
Alice: Hahaha, I get oil on my clothes every day.
Jake:对 你如果
Jake: Yeah, if you...
Alice:每天都在洗衣服
Alice: I do laundry every day.
Jake:对你带着眼镜一直洗衣服啊
Jake: Yeah, you wear glasses and keep doing laundry?
Jake:确实知道你是洗衣服干啥
Jake: I totally get that you do laundry.
Alice:对然后我一直在擦擦桌子
Alice: Yeah, and I keep wiping the table.
Lucia:哦靠
Lucia: Oh damn.
Jake:啊 这个没问题 对
Jake: Ah, that's no problem, yeah.
Lucia:主要是研究者不好研究我这些
Lucia: Mainly because researchers can't really study me.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: Whatever.
Jake:啥啥啥
Jake: What, what, what?
Lucia:主要是研究者不知道这个人是我就行
Lucia: Mainly because researchers don't know it's me, that's enough.
Jake:OKOK
Jake: OK, OK.
Alice:我无所谓
Alice: I don't care.
Alice:那那是不是我们就要那个
Alice: So, so does that mean we have to...
Lucia:要不然它就会发现我经常在摸鱼
Lucia: Otherwise, they'll find out I'm slacking off often.
Jake:那这个太常见了
Jake: That's too common.
Jake:哈哈哈这是人类本质
Jake: Hahaha, that's human nature.
Alice:那我们这个什么
Alice: So, what about this...
Lucia:人类的本质是摸鱼 好 不是
Lucia: Human nature is slacking off. Okay, no...
Alice:我要说啥来着
Alice:坏了 找不着了
Alice: Oh no, I can't find it.
Alice:真找不着了
Alice: I really can't find it.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Alice:忘了说一半忘了
Alice: I forgot, I forgot halfway.
Alice:难受啊我现在很难受
Alice: I'm so upset, I'm really upset now.
Lucia:没事 你学学领导
Lucia: It's okay, just learn from the leaders.
Jake:想一想想一想想一想
Jake: Think about it, think about it, think about it.
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:想不起来
Jake: Can't remember?
Jake:不想了吧
Jake: Just forget it then.
Lucia:你看
Lucia: Look...
Jake:想不起来
Jake: Can't remember.
Jake:过两分钟就想起来了
Jake: You'll remember in a couple of minutes.
Lucia:要是过两分钟也想不起来那就
Lucia: If you can't remember in a couple of minutes, then...
Jake:那就忘掉
Jake: Then just forget it.
Alice:啊对对对别别别
Alice: Yeah, yeah, yeah, no, no, no.
Alice:就是我们这个
Alice: So, this is for us.
Alice:最后那个每个人的数据还会让自己看
Alice: At the end, everyone will be able to see their own data.
Alice:就是需要什么删什么或者之类的
Alice: You can delete whatever you need or something like that.
Jake:对我们会帮你们先删
Jake: Yes, we'll help you delete it first.
Jake:我回头给你们
Jake: I'll give it to you later.
Lucia:领导你没给我看
Lucia: Boss, you didn't show me.
Lucia:就是到达的那个视频
Lucia: The video that arrived.
Lucia:你忘记了
Lucia: You forgot.
Jake:啊就今天的这个
Jake: Ah, today's video.
Alice:我是不是没有到达的视频
Alice: I don't have the arrival video, do I?
Lucia:太皮了嗯
Lucia: You're so cheeky.
Jake:就是到达的视频
Jake: It's the arrival video.
Jake:就是今天放的那个
Jake: The one we played today.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yes.
Alice:我我是不是没有到达
Alice: I, I didn't arrive, did I?
Lucia:太P了
Lucia: So cheeky.
Lucia:但是这才是真的话
Lucia: But that's the truth.
Jake:你没有到达的视频
Jake: You don't have the arrival video.
Jake:因为他们没有录
Jake: Because they didn't record it.
Shure: 来杨老板
Shure: Come on, Jake.
Lucia:一般如果有志愿者去接你的话就有
Lucia: Usually, if there's a volunteer to pick you up, there's a video.
Shure: 该把这也开了吧
Shure: Should we turn this on too?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Alice:有但但没有录
Alice: There is, but it wasn't recorded.
Jake:开开开开
Jake: Turn it on, turn it on.
Alice:我以为录了无所谓
Alice: I thought it was recorded, so it doesn't matter.
Shure: 我把他们都叫下来
Shure: I'll call them all down.
Shure: 然后咱拍一个
Shure: Then we'll start one.
Jake:哎好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:来听响了
Alice: Come, listen to the sound.
Shure: ego life圆满收官
Shure: Ego life is coming to a perfect end.
Jake:好
Jake: Good.
Alice:明天打扫卫生
Alice: Clean up tomorrow.
Shure: 快快快快下来下来下来下来来
Shure: Quickly, quickly, come down, come down.
Lucia:收拾收拾卫生
Alice:这粉底都擦掉了
Alice: My foundation is all wiped off.
Lucia:一般在我们宿舍
Lucia: Usually in our dormitory.
Lucia:收拾收拾尾声的意思是
Lucia: Cleaning up the end means...
Lucia:这剩一块披萨的感觉
Lucia: It feels like there's only one piece of pizza left.
Lucia:收拾收拾尾声
Lucia: Cleaning up the end.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake:那他压力挺大的
Jake: So he's under a lot of pressure.
Alice:受不了 刘婷 解决一下
Alice: I can't take it, Liu Ting, handle it.
刘婷:干啥
Liu Ting: What?
Lucia:收拾收拾卫生哈哈哈
Jake:所以今天的那个视频要调点角度
Jake: So, today's video needs some angle adjustments.
Jake:还是什么
Jake: Or what?
Lucia:我还没看呢
Lucia: I haven't seen it yet.
Jake:你还没看到呢
Jake: You haven't seen it yet?
Alice:嗯没关系大家已经看了
Alice: Hmm, it's okay, everyone already saw it.
Lucia:嗯 你没放
Lucia: Hmm, you didn't play it.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:放太早了是吧
Lucia:对放的是我还在
Lucia: Yeah, what I played is still here.
Lucia:我咱俩是不是都没看
Lucia: Neither of us saw it, right?
Lucia:咱俩在下面我记得
Lucia: I remember we were downstairs.
Alice:对我没有看到
Alice: Yeah, I didn't see it.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake:拿出来看看
Jake: Take it out and look.
Jake:共赏佳叫什么
Jake: What's the name of this masterpiece?
Alice:感我能吃口又不想吃口
Alice: I feel like eating a bite but don't want to eat it.
Lucia:我也 其是我是有点想吃 但是有点不想吃
Lucia: Me too. Actually, I kind of want to eat it, but also kind of don't.
Alice:但是
Alice: But...
Alice:觉得扔了比较可惜
Alice: It feels wasteful to throw it away.
Lucia:冰箱    其实我们第二天又会买买买然后就是
Alice:我们我们每天的剩饭就是放冰箱
Alice: Our leftover food every day just goes in the fridge.
Alice:然后第二天把冰箱里的 不是
Alice: And the next day we throw away the stuff in the fridge.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:然后把冰箱里的东西丢掉
Alice: And then throw away the stuff in the fridge.
Lucia:因为剩的如果大家一起吃的话就不够
Lucia: Because if everyone eats the leftovers, it won't be enough.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia:这肯定会点新的
Lucia: So we'll definitely order something new.
Lucia:但是一点新的光吃新的就够
Lucia: But just eating the new stuff will be enough.
Alice:然后
Alice: And then...
Alice:然后新的又剩哈哈哈
Alice: And then the new stuff gets leftover, hahaha.
Lucia:最后麻烦
Lucia: It's a hassle in the end.
Alice:要不留两块你当夜宵吃
Alice: How about we save two pieces for you to eat as a midnight snack?
Alice:你晚上睡得晚吗你
Alice: Do you stay up late at night?
Alice:挺晚的你两点还给我发抖音
Alice: Pretty late, you were still sending me TikToks at 2 AM.
Alice:真服了
Alice: Seriously.
Lucia:你们是舍友还是
Lucia: Are you guys roommates or...
Alice:不是她是我的老公
Alice: No, she's my wife.
Lucia:也可可可以有
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Alice:就是好朋友
Alice: Just good friends.
Alice:哎这个是啥呀
Alice: Hey, what's this?
Lucia:这应该是薇薇的小旗子吧
Lucia: This should be Tasha's little flag, right?
Alice:这
Alice: This...
Alice:哦那可能是
Alice: Oh, maybe it is.
Alice:这这这是谁的快递拆没 哎
Alice: Whose package is this? Has it been opened? Hey...
Alice:这空的吗
Alice: Is it empty?
Alice:有东西不知道是啥
Alice: There's something inside, not sure what it is.
Lucia:所以你是他的老公吗
Lucia: So are you really her wife?
Alice:不是不是不是
Alice: No, no, no.
Lucia:我开玩笑的啦
Lucia: I'm just kidding.
Alice:我
Alice: I...
Shure: 小心崩到你的电脑哦
Shure: Be careful not to hit your computer.
Jake: 好嘞 我们先开香槟
Jake: Alright, let's open the champagne first.
Alice:让我来录一下
Alice: Let me record this.
Lucia:我开玩笑的
Lucia: I'm just kidding.
Lucia:开玩笑的
Lucia: Just kidding.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:321 哎
Alice: Three, two, one, hey...
Alice:让大家都出来
Alice: Let everyone come out.
Jake:不理你
Jake: Ignoring you.
Alice:9点了
Alice: It's 9 o'clock.
Shure: 他是不是偷偷说我坏话呢
Shure: Was he secretly talking bad about me?
Alice:找个想吃的味道吧
Alice: Find a flavor you want to eat.
Alice:我不想吃这个带香肠的
Alice: I don't want to eat this one with sausage.
Lucia:这个叫
Lucia: This is called...
Lucia:苏米  萨萨拉米 应该是萨拉米
Lucia: Sumi... Salami, it should be salami.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia:不过我不确定国内萨拉米正宗不正宗
Lucia: But I'm not sure if the salami here is authentic.
Alice:没有我想吃的
Alice: It's not what I want to eat.
Lucia:但是没关系 好吃就行
Lucia: But it's okay, as long as it's tasty.
Alice:全都有这个香肠
Alice: They all have this sausage.
Lucia:对你把香肠撕下来又不吃
Alice:那今天吃什么明天都一陀屎呢你咋不说呢
Alice: So what are we eating today? Tomorrow it'll all be crap anyway, why don't you say something?
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting
Alice:我怎么了
Alice: What about me?
Alice:不管它就这样
Alice: Just leave it as it is.
Alice:能不能帮我吃一顿
Alice: Can you join me for a meal?
刘婷:什么叫帮你吃一顿
Liu Ting: What do you mean by joining you for a meal?
刘婷:你不是自己想吃吗
Liu Ting: Don't you want to eat by yourself?
Alice:还是选了这个香肠的
Alice: I still chose the sausage.
Jake:边喝边聊
Jake: Drink and chat at the same time.
Lucia:帮他收拾一下卫生
Jake:边喝边聊
Jake: Drink and chat at the same time.
Alice:吃不吃
Alice: Are you eating or not?
Alice:沙子
Alice: Sand
Jack: 里面在进行激烈的八卦环节
Jack: They're having an intense gossip session inside.
Jack: 增加了香槟酒的这个开口效果
Jack: Adding the effect of champagne popping.
Jack: 敬请期待啊期待啊
Jack: Stay tuned, stay tuned.
Jack: 这个这个事情很显然啊
Jack: This thing is very obvious.
Jack: 这个事就是很
Jack: This matter is just very...
就是现在那个男生一定觉得
Jack: Now that guy must be thinking...
Nicous: 如果你后面还跟他去正常联系
Nicous: If you keep in touch with him normally...
Nicous: 他就会觉得这个人怎么一直吊着
Nicous: He'll think, why is this person always hanging on?
Nicous: 有没有一种可能
Nicous: Is there a possibility...
Nicous: 你觉得那些好兄弟都不喜欢你
Nicous: You think those good buddies don't like you...
Nicous: 所以你觉得无所谓
Nicous: So you don't care.
Jack: 对啊或他们就他们觉得对啊但是
Jack: Yeah, they think so too, but...
Nicous: 正好这个男的喜欢就一样了
Nicous: Just so happens that guy likes it, so it's all the same.
Katrina: 所以他觉得在他的视角
Katrina: So, from his perspective...
Katrina: 我邀请他就代表我喜欢他
Katrina: My invitation means I like him.
Nicous: 对而且而且
Nicous: Yeah, and also...
Nicous: 重点问题是我今天下午才坐到你旁边
Nicous: The key point is I just sat next to you this afternoon.
Lucia:什么逻辑
Lucia: What kind of logic is that?
Nicous: 你们俩就那样
Nicous: You two just...
Nicous: 硬坐了一下午
Nicous: Sat awkwardly all afternoon.
Nicous: 对啊哈哈哈
Nicous: Yeah, haha.
Katrina: 他都坐过来了我能跑吗
Katrina: He already sat down, could I run away?
Nicous: 那你应该喊那你应该喊一个董超超
Nicous: Then you should've called Jack over.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jack: 你没看我当时不往那坐吗
Jack: Didn't you see I didn't sit there?
Katrina: 坐我俩中间吗
Katrina: Sit between us?
Jack: 我当时都走了呀
Jack: I even left at that time.
Jack: 我本来坐在这
Jack: I was originally sitting here.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 你怎么一言不发就开呢
Katrina: Why did you start without saying anything?
Katrina: 就开呢还没录呢
Katrina: You started it, but it hasn't recorded yet.
Nicous: 对啊
Nicous: Yeah.
我给你塞回去
I'll put it back for you.
男嘉宾:你重新再开一遍
Male Guest: Start it again.
Jack: 你再开一回吧
Jack: Start it again.
Shure: 我真
Shure: I really...
Jack: 没摇吧
Jack: Didn't shake it, right?
Lucia:塞回去气不够了
Lucia: Putting it back, there's not enough air.
Shure: 我摇了我真摇了
Shure: I shook it, I really did.
Jack: 多摇点再来一回再
Jack: Shake it more, do it again.
Shure: 在
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 再来一条
Shure: One more time.
Shure: 这玩意怎么塞回去啊 哥
Shure: How do you put this thing back in, bro?
Jake:他 他是
Jake: He... he is...
Lucia:外面还挺冷的
Lucia: It's pretty cold outside.
Jake:他是谁啊
Jake: Who is he?
其他:哎是那天这个还有个塞
Others: Oh, that day there was another plug.
Jake:哎呀 我草
Jake: Oh, damn.
Shure: 我把还有几个
Shure: I have a few more.
Lucia:我把洗
Lucia: I'll wash it.
Lucia:明天有什么
Lucia: What's tomorrow?
Lucia:有雨
Lucia: There's rain.
Katrina: 就是男女对唱
Katrina: It's a duet.
Katrina: 他非要我看他的眼睛
Katrina: He insists I look into his eyes.
Shure: 嘬一口吧
Shure: Take a sip.
Nicous: 因为如果因为如果他真的很
Nicous: Because if... if he really...
Alice:吃什么瓜
Alice: What are you eating?
Lucia:我把它这个烟抽一根算了
Lucia: I'll just smoke this cigarette.
Shure: 真的懒得刷了拿纸杯吧
Shure: Really too lazy to wash, use a paper cup.
拿纸杯吧
Use a paper cup.
Lucia:算了
Lucia: Forget it.
Shure: 可以用纸杯了吗
Shure: Can we use paper cups now?
Jake:可以可以可以
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure: 走了
Shure: Let's go.
Jack: 走掉了
Jack: It's gone.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Shure的女友:他真的有
Nurse: He really has...
Shure的女友:就是他整个人注意力都在
Shure's GF: His entire attention was on it.
Nicous: 不是你哦
Nicous: Not you, okay?
Jack: 就是这个点
Jack: That's the point.
Nicous: 你找男生
Nicous: You're looking for guys.
Katrina: 他没有普通朋友
Katrina: He doesn't have ordinary friends.
Shure的女友:就那天
Shure's GF: Just that day.
Nicous: 没出的问题
Nicous: No problems occurred.
Lucia:我也没吃上啊
Lucia: I didn't get to eat either.
Nicous: 是他出问题
Nicous: He had a problem.
Lucia:咱们不是在这外边收拾卫生了吗
Shure: 来杨老板
Shure: Come on, Jake.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: ego life
Shure: Ego life.
Jake:哎大卖大卖
Jake: Hey, big sales, big sales.
Shure: 大卖了
Shure: Big sales.
Shure: 圆满结束了
Shure: Perfect ending.
Shure: 基本上
Shure: Basically.
Shure: 他还嘚开车呢
Nicous: 解说是
Nicous: The commentary is...
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 谁要开车
Lucia: Who's driving?
Lucia:你要开车啊
Lucia: You're driving?
Alice:嗯干嘛
Alice: Hmm, what's up?
Jake:那你喝点橙汁吧
Jake: Then have some orange juice.
女嘉宾:可惜了啊
Female Guest: What a pity.
Jake:要不
Jake: Or else...
Nicous: 没事没事
Nicous: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia:可惜了了
Lucia: What a pity.
Nicous: 我不喝
Nicous: I don't drink.
Alice:啊来吧
Alice: Ah, come on.
Jake:你喝点桃汁吧
Jake: Have some peach juice.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake:白水啊
Jake: Plain water?
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thank you.
Alice:破 破戒了
Alice: Breaking the rule.
Alice:农夫微醺水
Alice: Farmer's lightly drunk water.
Shure: 还有还有谁 来点吧
Shure: Anyone else? Have some.
Jake:哈哈哈可以可以
Jake: Haha, it's fine, it's fine.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 来点吧路亚
Shure: Have some, Luya.
Jake:嗯好的
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Lucia:啊 好的
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Shure: 客气
Shure: No problem.
Shure的女友:觉得啊这个人好像对我有意思
Shure's GF: I feel like this person is interested in me.
Shure的女友:那种男生你都可以归为
Shure's GF: You can categorize those kinds of guys as...
Lucia:哇好多泡泡
Lucia: Wow, so many bubbles.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Alice:这多少度啊
Alice: What's the alcohol percentage?
Nicous: 喝出了粮食酒的感觉
Nicous: It tastes like grain liquor.
Lucia:气泡酒可能一般11-15左右
Lucia: Sparkling wine is usually around 11-15%.
Shure: 11
Shure: 11.
Alice:这么辣吗
Alice: Is it that spicy?
Alice:我现在口味这么淡吗
Alice: Have my taste buds become so mild?
Shure: 11.5对 不它
Shure: 11.5, right? No, it's...
Alice:才十来度
Alice: Only about ten degrees.
Jake:来来敬敬敬
Jake: Come on, cheers, cheers, cheers.
女嘉宾:怎么
Female Guest: What?
Jake:你的好朋友来
Jake: Your good friend is here.
Alice:感觉我退化了吗
Alice: Do I feel like I've regressed?
Shure: 来一杯
Shure: Have a drink.
Alice:可能吧我已经很久不喝酒了哦
Alice: Maybe, I haven't drunk in a long time.
Alice:你倒点吧
Alice: Pour some.
Nicous: 我不要
Nicous: I don't want any.
Jack: 我晚上开车呢
Jack: I have to drive tonight.
Alice:那你拿个这干啥
Alice: Then why did you take this?
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Lucia:一点撤不开
Lucia: Can't back out now.
Alice:神经
Alice: You're so silly.
Shure: 还有谁没有吗
Shure: Who else doesn't have one?
Shure: OK都有了吧
Shure: Okay, everyone has one, right?
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: 你你你来一杯吗
Shure: You, you, you want a drink?
女嘉宾:不用不用
Female Guest: No, no.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Alice:我那啥了
Alice: I... what?
Shure: 我们举杯敬
Shure: Let's raise our glasses.
Shure: 敬ego来来先先敬ego life一杯
Shure: Cheers to ego, come on, first a toast to ego life.
Shure: 然后再再说这个来
Shure: Then we'll talk about this, come on.
Shure: 哈哈哈来来来ego life哎
Shure: Hahaha, come on, come on, ego life.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay
男嘉宾: 好
Male Guest: Okay
刘婷:没事还会有还会有
Liu Ting: It's alright, there will be more chances.
Shure: 谁问的倒吗
Shure: Who asked if it would be overturned?
Lucia:还有还有
Lucia: There's more, there's more.
Lucia:没倒完呢
Lucia: It's not finished yet.
Shure: OK
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Jake:说到哪了
Jake: Where were we?
Katrina: 我我真的很想知道
Katrina: I, I really want to know.
Katrina: 那他11月份的时候跟我分开
Katrina: He broke up with me in November.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks
Katrina: 分开就这样拥抱一下
Katrina: We just hugged when we broke up.
Katrina: 我以为是礼节
Katrina: I thought it was just a formality.
Katrina: 就是有一种意思
Katrina: It meant something else.
Nicous: 谁跟暧昧拥抱一下
Nicous: Who would hug ambiguously?
Nicous: 不会的不会的
Nicous: No way, no way.
Nicous: 绝对不会
Nicous: Definitely not.
Jack: 这国内啊
Jack: This is how it is in the country.
Katrina: 没有就是就是
Katrina: No, it's just that...
Katrina: 我感觉这张脸不是啊
Katrina: I feel like this face is not...
Jack: 这国内啊
Jack: This is how it is in the country.
Alice:我去我要吃这个
Alice: I'm going to eat this.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed
Shure的女友:能完成你觉得所有的男生对你啊
Shure's GF: Can you complete, you think all the guys treat you...
Alice:你给我分一下
Alice: Share some with me.
Shure的女友:你觉得OK
Shure's GF: You think it's OK?
Lucia:我吃
Lucia: I'll eat it.
Shure的女友:你就可以把他归到啊
Shure's GF: You can categorize him as...
Lucia:但我想进微波炉打一下
Lucia: But I want to heat it in the microwave.
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure
Lucia:你可以先撕给我
Lucia: You can tear it for me first.
Lucia:然后我放微波炉里打一下
Jack: 分开的时候拥抱一下
Jack: Hugged when parting.
Alice:吃凉的
Alice: Eat it cold.
Jack: 生病的时候给你买药
Jack: Bought you medicine when sick.
Lucia:因为外边太冷了
Lucia: It's too cold outside.
Jack: 今天过去坐你旁边啊
Jack: Sat next to you today.
今Jack: 天今天就是今天
Jack: Today, just today.
Lucia:大葱晚 哦算了没事
Lucia: Green onions... oh never mind.
Jack: 这一天你生病了还给你买药
Jack: On that day, you were sick and I bought you medicine.
Katrina: 他坐我旁边
Katrina: He sat next to me.
Lucia:反正就算我吃不完
Lucia: Anyway, even if I can't finish eating...
Katrina: 好奇怪我都我一个人坐在那
Katrina: It was so strange, I was sitting there alone.
Lucia:别人应该也也也吃不完
Lucia: Others probably can't finish it either.
Katrina: 他非要从凳子上坐过来
Katrina: He insisted on sitting over from his chair.
Jack: 生病给你买药还不奇怪吗
Jack: Isn't it strange to buy you medicine when you're sick?
女嘉宾:盖死都怪怪
Female Guest: It's so weird.
Lucia:我我拿哪个
Lucia: Which one should I take?
Shure的女友:这还不能说明问题吗
Shure's GF: Doesn't that explain things?
Lucia:这这个就刚放这是吧
Lucia: This one was just placed here, right?
Lucia:嗯我去拿这盘
Lucia: I'll take this plate then.
Shure: 我天啊 你的
Shure: Oh my, yours...
Jake: 是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:拿个纸 刘婷
Alice: Grab a napkin, Liu Ting.
Shure:  AI能分析明白这个吗
Shure: Can AI understand this?
Alice:纸
Alice: Napkin.
Jake: 我觉得能
Jake: I think it can.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh wow.
Jake:我觉得AI已经能分析明白
Jake: I think AI can already understand it.
Alice:给这来给这来 哎呀
Alice: Here, take this. Oh dear.
Shure: AI能分清明白你这个是吗
Shure: Can AI really figure this out?
Jake:您这得 它得他得训练训练你
Jake: You see, it needs to train with you.
Jack: 我感觉我们几个毛都已经能推测出来
Jack: I feel like we could already guess it.
Shure的女友:大前天
Shure's GF: The day before yesterday.
Alice:来吧这是一只
Alice: Here, this is one.
Shure的女友:对大前天
Shure's GF: Yes, the day before yesterday.
Shure的女友:修跟我打视频电话嘛
Shure's GF: Shure had a video call with me.
刘婷:这是一只凤凰嗯
Liu Ting: This is a phoenix, right?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Uh-huh.
刘婷:今天的淋雨感冒了
Liu Ting: He got rained on and caught a cold today.
Shure的女友:然后视频电话呀
Shure's GF: Then there was a video call.
刘婷:所以他咳嗽了
Liu Ting: So he was coughing.
刘婷:他变成了一只落汤凤凰
Liu Ting: He turned into a soaked phoenix.
Shure的女友:哎你在说什么
Shure's GF: Hey, what are you talking about?
刘婷:没了没了
Liu Ting: That's it, that's it.
Jake:什么什么
Jake: What? What?
Shure的女友:对然后然后然后你不是在那跟他讲
Shure's GF: Yeah, and then you were talking to him.
Alice:没了
Alice: That's it.
刘婷:10秒钟之内吗
Liu Ting: Within 10 seconds?
Shure的女友:就是啊OK
Nurse: Yeah, exactly, OK.
Shure的女友:就是一个什么北欧的男生
Nurse: It was some Nordic guy.
Alice:弱智
Alice: Idiot.
Shure: 那那是另一个
Shure: No, that was someone else.
Lucia:我想再来一点
Lucia: I want a bit more.
Shure的女友:我知道是另一个
Nurse: I know it was someone else.
Alice:我确实不美
Alice: I'm really not pretty.
Shure的女友:我现在知道了
Nurse: I know now.
Shure的女友:然后当时我来的时候
Nurse: And then when I came here...
Lucia:你要吃吗
Lucia: Do you want to eat?
Katrina: 我以为是我是捂得高高的
Katrina: I thought it was me, I was covering up.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:那确实
Jake: That's true.
那确实
Katrina: 我感觉你耳朵这样
Katrina: I feel like your ears are like this.
Shure的女友:然后然后当时看到
Nurse: And then, then when I saw...
Shure的女友:我以为是你把他约出来了
Nurse: I thought you asked him out.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure的女友:因为那个不敢约
Nurse: Because he didn't dare to ask.
Lucia:我现在特别好奇
Lucia: Now I'm really curious.
Lucia:他原本不切开会有多大
Lucia: How big would it be if he didn't cut it?
Nicous: 有胆小鬼
Nicous: There's a coward.
Shure的女友:奥然哈哈
Nurse: Oh, I see, haha.
Jake:为啥
Jake: Why?
Lucia:没有看到他那造型
Lucia: Haven't you seen his style?
Shure: 你约他一顿饭呢
Shure: Why don't you ask him for a meal?
Shure的女友:约出来了
Nurse: Asked him out.
Shure的女友:然后你能不能别倒了喝两口
Nurse: And then, can you not pour it, just drink some?
Shure: 能不能别倒了喝两口姐
Shure: Can you not pour it, just drink some, sis?
Alice:我呢
Alice: What about me?
Jack: 哦靠 cp cp
Jack: Oh, wow, CP, CP.
刘婷:它嗓子比较痒哦
Liu Ting: His throat is quite itchy, oh.
Katrina: 我当时真感觉
Katrina: At that time, I really felt...
刘婷:然后他就他就他就吃了一个泡椒鸡
Liu Ting: And then he, he, he ate a pickled pepper chicken.
Nicous: 你越不能把这张照片发给他
Nicous: You can't send this photo to him.
Nicous: 你要把你们俩照片发给他
Nicous: You should send him a picture of you two.
Jake:来瞧一瞧瞧一瞧
Jake: Come on, take a look.
Nicous: 你把第二张照片发给他他就赢麻了
Nicous: If you send him the second photo, he'll be so happy.
Lucia:我这个
Lucia: This one...
Shure的女友:什么结婚照
Shure's GF: What wedding photo?
刘婷:泡椒凤爪
Liu Ting: Spicy chicken feet.
Lucia:眼睛老反光
Lucia: My eyes keep reflecting the light.
刘婷:去里面挠了一下喉咙
Liu Ting: I scratched my throat a bit inside.
Nicous: 你就给爽到了到
Nicous: You really enjoyed it.
嘉宾:第二张照片发给这男的
Guest: Send the second photo to this guy.
嘉宾:他直接作壁纸了
Guest: He immediately made it his wallpaper.
男嘉宾:对他他他直接就就就
Male Guest: Yeah, he just, just...
男嘉宾:颅内高潮颅内高潮
Male Guest: Brain orgasm, brain orgasm.
Shure的女友:我我真的感觉
Shure's GF: I really feel...
Shure的女友:就是当时看到你们俩的状态
Shure's GF: When I saw you two at that moment...
Shure的女友:我以为他是那个人
Shure's GF: I thought he was the one.
Lucia:哎好看
Lucia: Oh, it looks good.
Shure的女友:然后我说呃OK
Shure's GF: Then I was like, okay...
Shure的女友:可能这个人
Shure's GF: Maybe this person...
Katrina: 可是我对他没有那种很主动的行为
Katrina: But I didn't take any initiative towards him.
刘婷:这个不会也被录下来了吧
Liu Ting: This won't be recorded too, right?
男嘉宾:来来来
Male Guest: Come on, come on.
Katrina: 我都没跟他说什么话呀
Katrina: I didn't say much to him.
Jake:内部数据
Jake: Internal data.
Jack: 分析一下
Jack: Analyze it.
Alice:肯定啊 这眼镜呢
Alice: Of course, where are the glasses?
女嘉宾:我觉得挺正常的
Female Guest: I think it's normal.
Katrina: 因为我觉得因为我觉得尴尬了
Katrina: Because I felt awkward.
女嘉宾:我觉得挺正常的
Female Guest: I think it's normal.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: It doesn't matter.
Jack: 不知道我们这属于这一段
Jack: I don't know if we belong to this section.
Alice:人工智能真的会不理解你在干什么
Alice: AI really won't understand what you're doing.
Jack: 属于因号此类吧
Jack: It's probably this category.
男嘉宾:可能正常的就是这个图片组
Male Guest: Maybe it's just this set of pictures.
Shure的女友:无所谓
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter.
女嘉宾:平等的撞死所有人
Female Guest: Equally crash everyone.
Shure的女友:就是在这几天就是享受就好了
Shure's GF: Just enjoy these few days.
男嘉宾:这个系列
Male Guest: This series...
Jack: 这个这个主要得有系列
Jack: This, this mainly needs a series.
Shure的女友:无所谓
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter.
男嘉宾:我到时候可以用这个数据集多多来
Male Guest: I can use this dataset more later.
Shure的女友:sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry.
Jack: 多多多来一次
Jack: Do it again.
Katrina: 居然是这样的
Katrina: It turned out like this.
Shure的女友:sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry.
Katrina: 居然是这样子
Katrina: So that's how it is.
Alice:笑死我了
Alice: I'm dying of laughter.
Shure的女友:邀请你
Shure's GF: Inviting you
男嘉宾:没有没有你谋生哦
Male Guest: No, no, you're making a living.
Alice:来看一遍
Alice: Let's watch it again.
Katrina: 确实北欧男不来
Katrina: Indeed, Nordic guys don't come.
Shure的女友:对就是你活动娱乐活动就是怎么讲
Shure's GF: Yes, your activity, entertainment activity, how to say...
Katrina: 是北欧男不喜欢然后
Katrina: It's that Nordic guys don't like it and then...
Shure的女友:你这种
Shure's GF: You know, this kind of...
男嘉宾:没有没有特别多
Male Guest: No, not that many.
Shure的女友:我来我我来北京
Shure's GF: I came to Beijing...
Jake:很多啦
Jake: There are many.
Lucia:该不知道这种话题的乐趣在哪里
Lucia: I don't understand the fun in this topic.
Shure的女友:我参加一个活动
Shure's GF: I attended an event.
Shure的女友:然后最后一天那个阿弗伦party
Shure's GF: And on the last day, that Afren party...
Jake:特别多是啥意思
Jake: What do you mean by many?
Jake:你这小地方
Jake: In your small place...
Jake:比这强劲的
Jake: Even stronger than this.
Shure的女友:我要邀请一个朋友
Shure's GF: I want to invite a friend.
Jake:几张照片了
Jake: How many photos?
Shure的女友:然后我邀请了你
Shure's GF: Then I invited you.
男嘉宾:还好
Male Guest: Not bad.
Alice:我真的
Alice: I really...
Shure的女友:然后你过来了
Shure's GF: And you came over.
Shure的女友:这件事情本身来讲
Shure's GF: This thing itself...
男嘉宾:数据
Male Guest: Data...
Jake:七八
Jake: Seven or eight...
Shure的女友:就是一个很暧昧的事情
Shure's GF: Is a very ambiguous thing.
Alice:为什么你每个视频都这么好笑呢
Alice: Why is every video of yours so funny?
男嘉宾:是你们得看那个摄像头里面的啊啊
Male Guest: You guys should look at the camera footage...
Alice:我请问啊
Alice: May I ask...
女嘉宾:这两个发给你
Female Guest: I'll send you these two.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:可以
Lucia: Okay.
刘婷:你笑点很低呀
Liu Ting: You laugh easily.
女嘉宾:这两个还蛮好的嗯
Female Guest: These two are quite good.
Alice:是吗那别人怎么不这么好笑
Alice: Really? Then why don't others find it so funny?
Shure的女友:非常actually
Shure's GF: Very actually...
女嘉宾:这个在搅搅的
Female Guest: This one is stirring...
Katrina: CPU烧了
Katrina: The CPU is burned out.
男嘉宾:因为因为因为只能邀
Male Guest: Because, because, because I could only invite...
男嘉宾:因为因为只能邀你只邀请到了一个
Male Guest: Because, because I could only invite one person...
女嘉宾:搅搅哈
Female Guest: Stir it, stir it.
男嘉宾:你只邀请到了一个
Male Guest: You could only invite one person.
刘婷:我们俩天生一对
Liu Ting: We are a perfect match.
Shure的女友:yeah just one对
Shure's GF: Yeah, just one pair.
男嘉宾:对你只邀请到一个这个是
Male Guest: Yes, you could only invite one person, so...
男嘉宾:你只邀请到一个
Male Guest: You could only invite one.
Lucia:你可以选帧
男嘉宾:这个事情就很就很tricky
Male Guest: This thing is very tricky.
Lucia:你觉得哪帧好看就选哪帧
Shure: 而且你得回
Shure: Also, you have to...
男嘉宾:邀请的人家
Male Guest: Invite people.
刘婷:要放几遍
Liu Ting: How many times do you want to play it?
刘婷:我问你要放几遍
Liu Ting: I'm asking you, how many times do you want to play it?
男嘉宾:你邀请不是人家问的你
Male Guest: You invite, isn't it because they asked you?
Alice:你管我你管我
Alice: Why do you care? Why do you care?
Shure的女友:对是你是你问他
Shure's GF: Yes, you asked him.
Shure的女友:就是可能对你来讲
Shure's GF: It's just that maybe for you...
Shure的女友:你筛选的选项就是啊在北京我认识
Shure's GF: The options you filtered were those you knew well in Beijing...
Shure的女友:还可以很熟
Shure's GF: And you could invite people.
Shure的女友:然后我可以邀请人
Shure's GF: So you can invite people.
Shure的女友:对他来说就是
Shure's GF: For him, it's just...
Shure的女友:对他来说就是哦他邀请我
Shure's GF: For him, it's just, oh, he invites me...
Shure的女友:只有一个我要邀请人
Shure's GF: There's only one, I need to invite people.
Shure的女友:我邀请人家哇
Shure's GF: I need to invite people, wow.
Jack: 女孩子在国内的语境
Jack: In the context of girls in China...
Jack: 女孩子主动邀请这种选择
Jack: Girls taking the initiative to invite is...
Nicous: 而且那个男生他就是在
Nicous: And that guy, he is just...
Nicous: 他需要的是
Nicous: What he needs is...
Shure: 前所未有的数据集
Shure: An unprecedented data set.
Katrina: 我北京我不待几天
Katrina: I won't stay in Beijing for long.
Katrina: 然后别担心一起见
Katrina: Don't worry, we'll meet up.
女嘉宾:我在看他在割双眼皮的一个
Female Guest: I'm watching him getting double eyelid surgery.
Katrina: 见个面就不担心
Katrina: Let's just meet up, don't worry.
Shure的女友:别担心掉人生了
Shure's GF: Don't worry about it.
Jack: 他现在肯定已经在回去的路上想着
Jack: He's probably already on his way back thinking...
Lucia:这是什么
Lucia: What's this?
女嘉宾:这是他在试验双眼皮
Female Guest: This is him testing his double eyelids.
男嘉宾:到时候回武汉的时候
Male Guest: When I go back to Wuhan
Jake:他有时候是
Jake: Sometimes he is
男嘉宾:我一般去北京西站送
Male Guest: I usually go to Beijing West Station to see off
女嘉宾:但是我看他这个封面区别还是蛮大的
Female Guest: But I see his cover is quite different
Jake: 点
Jake: Point
男嘉宾:你也是这样的必是这样的
Male Guest: You're also like this, must be like this
Jake: 点
Jake: Point
Nicous: 我也在规划五一去武汉
Nicous: I'm also planning to go to Wuhan on May Day
Alice:紫棠给你看一个
Alice: Violet, show you something
Nicous: 就是在纠结
Nicous: Just struggling with it
Katrina: 他也邀请过我
Katrina: He also invited me
Shure的女友:6666 stop
Sister: 6666 stop
Katrina: 一起去玩
Katrina: Let's go have fun together
Jack: 卧槽一起出去玩你还要
Jack: Damn, you still want to go out together
Alice:弱智视频
Alice: Silly video
Lucia:是刚才那个吗
Lucia: Is it that one just now?
Katrina: 但是我当然是
Katrina: But of course I
Katrina: 到时候再说
Katrina: Let's talk about it later
Alice:啊不是吧
Alice: Ah, no way
Nicous: 不是一起出去玩
Nicous: Not going out together
Alice:我也不知道是不是
Alice: I don't know either
Nicous: 就是很明显很难邀请的
Nicous: It's just obviously very hard to invite
Alice:你看
Alice: Look
Jake:这很难邀请的
Jake: This is very hard to invite
Jake:很难出口的邀请来
Jake: It's hard to extend an invitation
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
男嘉宾:而且得并没有得到一个你直接否定的
Male Guest: And I didn't get a direct rejection from you
Jack: 怎么说呢
Jack: How should I put it
Jack: 因为他要求你
Jack: Because he asked you
女嘉宾:好牛啊
Female Guest: So cool
Katrina: 因为我觉得拒绝很尴尬
Katrina: Because I think rejecting is awkward
Alice:笑死
Alice: Laughing to death
Lucia:好牛啊
Lucia: So cool
Katrina: 就是大家是很好的朋友
Katrina: Because we are really good friends
Jack: 男女生朋友单独一点
Jack: Male and female friends being alone
Jack: 但感觉就是就是从那个他的视角
Jack: But from his perspective
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah
Shure的女友:他可能从从女孩子视角来讲
Sister: He might see it from a girl's perspective
Lucia:就是有点冷
Lucia: It's a bit cold
Lucia:但是真的很搞笑
Lucia: But it's really funny
Lucia:你们多加几个关键词我觉得会火
Lucia: If you add a few more keywords, I think it will go viral.
Shure的女友:不要担心任何事情
Shure's GF: Don't worry about anything.
Shure的女友:你给他吊就行了
Shure's GF: Just let him hang out, it's fine.
Alice:刘婷 又跑哪去了
Alice: Liu Ting, where did you run off to again?
Shure的女友:为什么男生有这个特征
Shure's GF: Why do guys have this trait?
Shure的女友:女生也可以有啊
Shure's GF: Girls can have it too.
Shure的女友:whatever
Shure's GF: Whatever.
Lucia:然后大家就会争相模仿
Shure的女友:吊就行了我喜欢
Shure's GF: Just let him hang out, I like it.
Alice:她每天都在这样 每天
Alice: She does this every day, every single day.
Shure的女友:你开心就好
Shure's GF: As long as you're happy.
男嘉宾:就当天晚上
Male Guest: Just that night.
男嘉宾:这不是正常吗
Male Guest: Isn't that normal?
Jack: 当天就有这么好的吗
Jack: Was it that good on the same day?
Shure: 别我害怕
Shure: No, I'm scared.
Jack: 过夜啊对啊
Jack: Stay overnight? Yeah, right.
Jack: 当天就到这份上了
Jack: That same day it got to that point?
Shure: 要不我们三个
Shure: How about the three of us...
Shure: 不要不要
Shure: No, no.
女嘉宾:抖音那个视频发给你了
Female Guest: I sent you that TikTok video.
Shure的女友:就是咱俩现在分手
Shure's GF: Like, we're breaking up now.
Shure的女友:我猜不来吧来斯宾
Shure's GF: I can't guess, come on, spin.
Alice:不是咱俩那那能看吗
Alice: No, can we even watch that?
Shure的女友:OK
Shure's GF: OK.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 哈哈哈这不是重点
Shure: Hahaha, that's not the point.
Jake:就预约了
Jake: It's just a reservation.
Jake:就是
Jake: Just...
Katrina: 但是我肯定不会跟他单独去啊
Katrina: But I definitely won't go with him alone.
Katrina: 那当时就是拒绝什么的
Katrina: So I refused at the time or something.
Lucia:再来点
Lucia: Have some more.
Katrina: 因为不好接受啊
Katrina: Because it's hard to accept.
Katrina: 我说我当时跟他去他真提出来这个
Katrina: I said, if I went with him and he really brought it up...
Jake:invitation就这个invitation
Jake: Invitation, just this invitation.
Alice:嘿嘿嘿 下班了吗 累
Alice: Hehehe, are you off work? Tired.
Lucia:对就说明他预期在出去玩之前
Lucia: Yes, it means he expected it before going out.
Jake:太BIOS
Jake: Too biased.
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What?
Shure的女友:不是我在想我就好受欢迎
Shure's GF: No, I was just thinking, I'm so popular.
Alice:我想上厕所
Alice: I need to use the bathroom.
Jake:今天又邀请来了
Jake: Today we invited again
Jake:不一样了给你说
Jake: It's different this time, let me tell you
Alice:你给我看个门
Alice: Watch the door for me
Shure: 你怎么每天就是照着镜子我好美
Shure: Why do you look in the mirror every day and think "I'm so beautiful"?
Shure: 然后晚上我好受欢迎
Shure: And then at night, "I'm so popular"
Lucia:我突然觉得这个
Lucia: I suddenly feel like
Lucia:这个白板配上这个包挺好看的
Lucia: This whiteboard with this bag looks pretty good
Alice:给我看着门 刘婷
Alice: Watch the door for me, Liu Ting
Lucia:这个决定拍一下
Lucia: Let's take a picture of this
Shure: 你这定位加的有点多
Shure: You've added too many location tags
Shure的女友:以后也是吧
Shure's GF: It will be the same in the future, right?
Shure: 好好看一下
Shure: Take a good look
Jake:你眼镜呢
Jake: Where are your glasses?
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay then
Katrina: 刚刚一直在充充电宝
Katrina: I was just charging the power bank
Katrina: 但是它还是显示没电
Katrina: But it's still showing no power
Jake:什么眼镜
Jake: What glasses?
Jake:就是什么充电宝
Jake: What kind of power bank?
Jake:就这种吗
Jake: Is it this kind?
Lucia:什么眼镜
Lucia: What glasses?
Shure: 可能没电了这个
Shure: Maybe it's out of power
Lucia:老板已经疯了
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright then
Jake:没关系这边有足够的数据
Jake: It's okay, there's enough data here
Jack: 今天今天你们
Jack: Today, today you guys
Jack: 今天你们有非常多份的
Jack: Today you have many copies of
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jack: 这个今天你们有非常多份的照片
Jack: Today you have many copies of photos
Shure: 妈妈带娃是吧
Shure: Moms taking care of kids, right?
Shure的女友:妈妈带娃是的
Shure's GF: Moms taking care of kids, yes
Jake:是的希望他以后能用到这个数据集
Jake: Yes, hopefully he can use this dataset in the future
男嘉宾:哎你你这个数据题研究一下
Male Guest: Hey, you should study this data problem
Shure的女友:我有点想跟他加个微信
Shure's GF: I kind of want to add him on WeChat
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes
Shure的女友:所以你跟他加可不可以
Shure's GF: So can you add him?
男嘉宾:这段我们没事这段我们可以搞成
Male Guest: This part, we can handle this part
Shure: 谁啊
Shure: Who?
Shure的女友:sorry please
Shure's GF: Sorry please
Shure: 来
Shure: Come
男嘉宾:这这段可以
Male Guest: This part can be done
Shure: 摄摄摄影师
Shure: Photographer, photographer.
Jake:知道
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 我们加个微信
Shure: Let's add each other on WeChat.
Shure: 后期后期
Shure: Post-production, post-production.
Shure: 这个照片对
Shure: This photo, right.
Shure的女友:哎哎哎毕业照是不是想我拍
Shure: Hey hey hey, you want me to take your graduation photo, right?
Lucia:嗯呵
Lucia: Hmm, yeah.
Shure: 一百三百几来着
Shure: One hundred, three hundred, how much was it?
Shure的女友:no
Shure: No.
Shure: 哎呀稍等
Shure: Oh, wait a second.
Shure: 真真
Shure: Really, really.
Shure的女友:给你打个折好吧
Shure: I'll give you a discount, okay?
女嘉宾:妈呀他大二才能看
Female Guest: Oh my, he can only watch it in sophomore year.
Nicous: 他不一定有时间过来
Nicous: He might not have time to come over.
Shure的女友:打折好吗
Shure: A discount, okay?
Shure的女友:给你们打5折
Lucia:哎你是研究生还是大四来着
Lucia: Hey, are you a graduate student or a senior?
女嘉宾:我是研究生
Female Guest: I'm a graduate student.
Shure的女友:啊我天
Shure: Oh my god.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure的女友:就修硕我朋友的话
Shure: If it's Shure, my friend...
Shure的女友:我可能直接就不要钱了
Shure: I might not charge at all.
Katrina: 他刚刚在这的时候还抱了我们
Katrina: He just hugged us when he was here.
Lucia:那你是什么专业的软件工程
Lucia: What major are you in, software engineering?
Jack: 在这都抱你
Jack: He hugged you here?
Katrina: 他说要走了
Katrina: He said he was leaving.
女嘉宾:是人工智能哦专业叫人工智能哦
Female Guest: It's artificial intelligence, the major is called artificial intelligence.
Katrina: 他说我们
Katrina: He said we...
Nicous: 不是真的抱了
Nicous: Did he really hug you?
Lucia:哦专业就是
Lucia: Oh, the major is...
女嘉宾:对软件工程还确实不太一样
Female Guest: Yeah, software engineering is actually a bit different.
Katrina: 下一面什么时候再见就会抱你
Katrina: Next time we meet, he will hug you again.
女嘉宾:就是要搞什么神经网络那种
Female Guest: It's about neural networks and stuff.
Jack: 不是他怎么抱的
Jack: How did he hug you?
Shure的女友:呃我拿一下我拿一下
Shure: Uh, let me take it, let me take it.
女嘉宾:软件工程就可能是写扎瓦的哦
Female Guest: Software engineering might involve writing Java.
Shure的女友:我现在有点看不清哇那个男女
Shure: I can't really see clearly now, the male and female...
Jack: 国内男女收
Jack: Domestic gender ratio...
Katrina: 因为他每次都这样
Katrina: Because he always does that.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
男嘉宾:他每次都爽了
Male Guest: He always enjoys it.
Shure的女友:你今天喝成这个样子
Shure's GF: You're this drunk today.
Nicous: 你你是会总结的
Nicous: You, you're good at summarizing.
Shure的女友:明天还在吗
Shure's GF: Will you still be here tomorrow?
男嘉宾:但但绝对不会放你过来
Male Guest: But they definitely won't let you come over.
Shure的女友:公司大概要两个半小时啊
Shure's GF: The company takes about two and a half hours.
Jake:不是 是什么同学
Jake: No, what classmate?
Shure的女友:就是石砖
Shure's GF: It's just a stone brick.
Jake:什么同学
Jake: What classmate?
Lucia:对我老家就是西安的
Lucia: Yes, my hometown is Xi'an.
Jake:什么关系
Jake: What's the relationship?
Katrina: 但是我会经常在新疆那边
Katrina: But I often stay in Xinjiang.
Shure的女友:嗯no no no
Shure's GF: Hmm, no no no.
Katrina: 那时候认识的
Katrina: We met at that time.
Shure的女友:一转10转13是
Shure's GF: One turn, 10 turns, 13 is...
女嘉宾:嗯挺好的
Female Guest: Hmm, pretty good.
Nicous: 是保研认识的网友
Jack: 国内男女生朋友
Jack: Male and female friends in China.
女嘉宾:我老我老家是湖北的
Female Guest: My hometown is Hubei.
Jake:保研认识
Jake: Bao Yan met...
Jake:什么意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Jack: 线下
Jack: Offline.
Jake:他是什么学阶
Jake: What grade is he in?
Katrina: 就是就在5月份的时候小红书认识
Katrina: It was in May, we met on Xiaohongshu.
Katrina: 然后就保研搭子
Katrina: Then he became my Bao Yan buddy.
Katrina: 然后那个时候都发了一些链接
Katrina: And at that time, we shared some links.
女嘉宾:所以你就是一直也在湖北
Female Guest: So you've been in Hubei all along?
Lucia:所以你就是一直在
Lucia: So you've been in...
Katrina: 开营链接
Katrina: Opening camp links.
Katrina: 然后大家互通一些消息
Katrina: And then we exchanged some information.
女嘉宾:对我从高考之前就在湖北
Female Guest: Yes, I've been in Hubei since before the college entrance exam.
Katrina: 然后呢后来9月份也没说什么
Katrina: And then in September, there wasn't much said.
女嘉宾:然后来北京
Female Guest: Then I came to Beijing.
Katrina: 然后11月份的时候
Katrina: And in November...
Katrina: 他来武汉找我玩了一趟
Katrina: He came to Wuhan to visit me.
Katrina: 以后就开始每天发消息
Katrina: And we started messaging every day.
Jake:哦那也那确实那
Jake: Oh, that's indeed...
Katrina: 然后就到现在都不职业到
Katrina: And now, we're not in the same profession.
Jake:那这个时间线很标准啊
Jake: That timeline is very standard.
Jake:很很标准
Jake: Very, very standard.
Jack: 比较少因为我还是更爱拍朋友
Jack: Not often, because I still prefer taking photos of friends.
女嘉宾:是新加坡的一个
Female Guest: It's in Singapore.
女嘉宾:就是跟着老板面试
Female Guest: I was just following the boss for an interview.
Jake:哎
Jake: Oh.
男嘉宾:你们俩聊天记录什么频率
Male Guest: How often do you guys chat?
男嘉宾:看聊天记录日期嗯
Male Guest: Check the chat history date, yeah.
女嘉宾:然后就跟着他参与一些项目
Female Guest: Then I just followed him to participate in some projects.
女嘉宾:也就是用来帮帮忙
Female Guest: Just to help out.
女嘉宾:就是没有说到特别恶心的地方
Female Guest: It wasn't particularly disgusting.
Jake:就走上正轨了
Jake: Then everything went smoothly.
男嘉宾:没怎么说话
Male Guest: Didn't talk much.
Jake:就是哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Just haha haha haha.
女嘉宾:但是帮忙也挺好的
Female Guest: But helping out was nice.
男嘉宾:没怎么说话
Male Guest: Didn't talk much.
男嘉宾:但是天天在聊
Male Guest: But chatted every day.
女嘉宾:真的在我额外的
Female Guest: Really, aside from my extra...
Nicous: 你不回一下
Nicous: Aren't you replying?
女嘉宾:我在研究生之外
Female Guest: Outside of my graduate studies...
Katrina: 回了我说我说
Katrina: I replied, I said...
女嘉宾:额外的能做一些事了解一些
Female Guest: I can do some additional things and learn something...
女嘉宾:这也挺好的啊
Female Guest: That's quite good.
Jake:来看一看
Jake: Let's take a look.
女嘉宾:看什么啊就是
Female Guest: Look at what?
男嘉宾:不是你看那个
Male Guest: No, check that...
Jake:啊就是哎这个错过的一个小影片
Jake: Ah, this is a little video we missed.
男嘉宾:看看那个日记
Male Guest: Check that diary.
Jack: 你看日记是不是每天都对
Jack: You look at the diary every day, right?
女嘉宾:这个错过的一个小影片啊
Female Guest: This little video we missed.
Jack: 你可以那个拿那个
Jack: You can take that...
Jack: 哈哈行了行了行了
Jack: Haha alright, alright.
女嘉宾:对你没
Female Guest: Yeah, you didn't...
女嘉宾:你没看到那个
Female Guest: You didn't see that...
女嘉宾:嗯这个影片
Female Guest: Uh, this video.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Uh-huh.
男嘉宾:建议这还说什么
Male Guest: Suggest what else can be said?
男嘉宾:建议立刻按C1处理
Male Guest: Suggest handling it with C1 immediately.
男嘉宾:你看他老上海都是你
Male Guest: Look, it's all about old Shanghai.
Nicous: 知道他自我介绍的时候说什么吗
Nicous: Do you know what he said during his self-introduction?
Nicous: 他说我叫杜叉叉AK
Nicous: He said, "My name is Du Chacha AKA..."
女嘉宾:这这个词都是有意思的
Female Guest: This, this term is interesting.
女嘉宾:这个词词都是有啊
Female Guest: These words are all there.
Nicous: 李宇轩的小刘宇轩的小跟班
Nicous: Li Yuxuan's little follower.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Nicous: 卧槽这还不明显吗
Nicous: Damn, isn't this obvious?
Jack: 我觉得这个倒没事
Jack: I think this is fine.
Jake:但是这个没有对应上画面
Jake: But this doesn't match the footage.
Jack: 但这个但这个东西已经就是
Jack: But this, but this thing is already...
Jake:因为实在是剪不过来了
Jake: Because it's impossible to edit it out.
女嘉宾:对
Female Guest: Right.
Jake:就是就是
Jake: It's just...
男嘉宾:但是就看
Male Guest: But just look at...
Shure的女友:调人像还是调整个构图
Shure: Adjust the portrait or the composition.
Jake:毕竟是
Jake: After all...
Lucia:噢
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:毕竟是presentation之前的一个小时嘛
Jake: After all, it's just an hour before the presentation.
Jack: 都会有吧
Jack: There will be some, right?
Jack: 我给你看一些
Jack: Let me show you some.
男嘉宾:不是这个
Male Guest: Not this one.
Jake:对吧you know
Jake: Right, you know.
女嘉宾:两个楼
Female Guest: Two floors.
女嘉宾:我跟我刚刚哥们也这样
Female Guest: My buddy and I are like this too.
男嘉宾:那你都主动给他分享啊
Male Guest: Then you proactively share with him?
Jake:就是被抓了一下
Jake: Just got caught once.
Katrina: 你说这种人会被抓到
Katrina: You mean people like this will get caught.
Nicous: 会哎呀
Nicous: They will, oh yeah.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh yeah.
女嘉宾:写的挺好的
Female Guest: It's written quite well.
Lucia:对对是那个软是那个那个
Lucia: Right, right, it's that soft, that...
Jack: 说实话啊他说话真的好多啊
Jack: Honestly, he talks a lot.
Jake: GBD写的
Jake: Written by GBD.
Lucia:啊 OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Jake:GPT写的
Jake: Written by GPT.
Jake:然后搜搜AI谱的曲
Jake: And then composed by AI.
男嘉宾:我就看你最近一直非常害怕
Male Guest: I see you've been really scared lately.
Shure的女友:但我感觉
Shure: But I feel...
Lucia:龙之队 哈哈哈
Lucia: Dragon team, hahaha.
男嘉宾:还发自拍哎呀
Male Guest: Still posting selfies, oh man.
Lucia:好厉害
Lucia: So impressive.
男嘉宾:因为他们其中一方是很凶的
Male Guest: Because one of them is very fierce.
Jake:竟然没看出来
Jake: Didn't even notice that.
Tasha:啊这个是修硕的词啊没对象
Tasha: Ah, this is Shure's line, no match.
男嘉宾:我看看我一当当
Male Guest: Let me see, I'll just do it.
Katrina: 没有我们俩后来
Katrina: No, we two later...
男嘉宾:没有办法
Male Guest: There's no way.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
男嘉宾:哦他没看着
Male Guest: Oh, he didn't see it.
男嘉宾:其实怎么讲
Male Guest: Actually, how to say...
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure的女友:很多时候就是大家去找男生的话
Shure's GF: Many times when everyone looks for guys...
Shure的女友:我一般找的都是工作上的
Shure's GF: I usually look for work-related ones.
Katrina: 找的基本就是就是
Katrina: What we look for is basically...
Lucia:我听见了 我说了谢谢
Lucia: I heard it, I said thank you.
Tasha:你有看过这段影像吗
Tasha: Have you seen this footage?
Shure的女友:男社会更在意构图而不是
Shure's GF: Men in society care more about composition rather than...
Lucia:没呢
Lucia: Not yet.
Lucia:对 啊谢谢
Lucia: Yes, ah, thank you.
Shure的女友:是他的状态
Shure's GF: His state.
Nicous: 你也给他发自拍
Nicous: You also send him selfies?
Lucia:我要我要确保一下
Lucia: I need to make sure.
Katrina: 当然啊
Katrina: Of course.
Lucia:他没有把我表情包剪进去
Lucia: He didn't cut my meme in.
Shure的女友:所以可能就是肠胃比较小
Shure's GF: So maybe his stomach is small.
Nicous: 没有吃我的
Nicous: Didn't eat mine.
Jake:放心你放心我有一点点审美虽然不多
Jake: Don't worry, don't worry, I have a bit of aesthetic sense, though not much.
男嘉宾:我不会给他发自拍
Male Guest: I won't send him selfies.
Lucia:谢谢你有偶像包袱
Lucia: Thank you, you have an idol burden.
男嘉宾:他也没有给我发自拍
Male Guest: He didn't send me selfies either.
Shure的女友:肠胃软件也是CS
Shure's GF: Gastrointestinal software is also CS.
Lucia:也不多但有一点谢谢
Lucia: Not much but a little, thank you.
Shure的女友:还是那个说CS挺想家的
Shure's GF: Still that CS really misses home.
Shure的女友:对反正你需要调
Shure's GF: Yes, anyway, you need to adjust.
Shure的女友:然后对你做色调什么
Shure's GF: And then adjust the color tone and stuff for you.
Shure的女友:然后那个香香皂稍微磨磨皮
Shure's GF: Then the fragrant soap slightly polishes the skin.
Lucia:啊Tasha的
Lucia: Ah, it's Tasha's.
Shure的女友:什么修修那种什么给大家
Shure's GF: What kind of editing, giving everyone...
男嘉宾:什么修修那种什么给大家
Male Guest: What kind of editing, giving everyone...
Katrina: 他参加了蛮多夏令营
Katrina: He attended quite a few summer camps.
Shure的女友:那个里地没他丰富
Shure's GF: There's not as much in that place.
Shure的女友:所以加他去一些商太门
Shure's GF: So add him to some business...
Lucia:好可爱呀哈哈
Lucia: So cute, haha.
Shure的女友:因为来了商太门
Shure's GF: Because Shang Taimen came
Shure的女友:我觉得北京商太门
Shure's GF: I think Beijing's Shang Taimen
Katrina: 但是没有那么喜欢的感觉
Katrina: But I don't really like it that much
Jake:有几个没剪进去因为实在是剪不进来
Jake: There are a few parts that didn't make it into the cut because they just couldn't fit
Jake:因为实在是没时间剪了
Jake: Because there really wasn't time to edit them
男嘉宾:就是女生对一个男生
Male Guest: So, a girl towards a guy
Alice: 是因为生活哈哈
Alice: It's because of life, haha
Jake: 开点了哈
Jake: Let's start, haha
Lucia:哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia:哦这个居然留住了
Lucia: Oh, this actually stayed
Lucia:可以可以特别棒
Lucia: It’s good, very good
Jake:妙
Jake: Wonderful
Lucia:特别好特别好
Lucia: Very good, very good
Jake:妙 妙啊
Jake: Wonderful, wonderful indeed
Jake:特别好
Jake: Very good
男嘉宾:我一般都秒
Male Guest: I usually do it instantly
Jake:谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you
Lucia:我们的六面体老板
Lucia: Our hexagonal boss
Lucia:哦 不是六面体老板
Lucia: Oh, not hexagonal boss
Shure的女友:但其实是有歧视
Shure's GF: But actually there is discrimination 社会问题
Shure的女友:恋大家会喜欢找女生
Shure's GF: People tend to like to find girls 性别问题
Lucia:六面体
Lucia: Hexagonal
Jake:我们的方形老板
Jake: Our square boss
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
男嘉宾:那肯定了
Male Guest: Of course
男嘉宾:女孩子呢
Male Guest: Girls
男嘉宾:现在这
Male Guest: Nowadays
Shure的女友:大家会觉得哦OK
Shure's GF: People would think, oh okay
Shure的女友:你去找女生
Shure's GF: You go find a girl 性别问题
你Shure的女友:整个人呢
Shure's GF: The whole person
Lucia:哎可以可以
Lucia: Hey, it’s okay, it’s okay
Jake:对回去再做
Jake: Yes, let's do it again later
Jack: 就你对对对
Jack: Yeah, yeah, right
Jake:再再加几个
Jake: Add a few more
男嘉宾:而且这年头确实也是有那个
Male Guest: Besides, these days, there is indeed that
Lucia:可可以的可以的
Lucia: It's fine, it's fine
男嘉宾:对很多这个会有这种需求
Male Guest: Yes, many people have this need
女嘉宾:他们还在八卦她
Female Guest: They are still gossiping about her
男嘉宾:你首先他肯定
Male Guest: You see, first of all
男嘉宾:他问你形象
Male Guest: He asks you about your image
Jake:对这个太容易八卦了
Jake: Yeah, this is too easy to gossip about.
男嘉宾:你为什么一直
Male Guest: Why do you keep...
Shure的女友:你背一下
Shure's GF: Just back off for a moment.
Jake:竟然还在八卦
Jake: Still gossiping?
Shure的女友:我不想我不想这这块被记录下来
Shure's GF: I don't want this part to be recorded.
Lucia:他们怎么还没有八卦完
Lucia: Why haven't they finished gossiping yet?
Alice:你想干什么
Alice: What do you want to do?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jake:咋地 嗯
Jake: What's up? Hmm?
Alice:一死谢罪
Alice: Die to apologize.
Tasha:下一盘是什么
Tasha: What's the next round?
Tasha:没有下一盘
Tasha: There's no next round.
Jake:没有下一趴就划水划到结束
Jake: If there's no next round, just slack off until the end.
Jake:划到没电
Jake: Until we run out of power.
Lucia:划到没电啊
Lucia: Until we run out of power, huh?
Jake:对就是各位加油把时间耗完
Jake: Yeah, just keep going and waste the time.
Lucia:好吧可是我充着充电宝他不会没电
Lucia: Okay, but I'm using a power bank, it won't run out.
Jake:就是没有sorry
Jake: There's no sorry.
Jake:你怂了
Jake: You're chickening out.
Lucia:OK I SEE
Lucia: OK, I see.
Lucia:但是以他现在的状态
Lucia: But in his current state...
刘婷:哎你带眼镜了吗
Liu Ting: Hey, are you wearing glasses?
Lucia:他有可能插着充电宝也没电对吧
Lucia: He might run out of power even with the power bank, right?
Jake:哦好的加油
Jake: Oh, alright, keep going.
Jake:充电宝加油
Jake: Power bank, keep going.
Alice:要带
Alice: Need to wear it.
Katrina: 大家都没有考虑这是什么啊
Katrina: Nobody is considering what this is.
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What is this?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:充电宝加油
Jake: Power bank, keep going.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:走要不戴
Jake: Let's go, put it on.
Jake:要不戴上吧要不戴上吧
Jake: Put it on, put it on.
Lucia:不喜欢吃瓜
Lucia: I don't like to gossip.
Lucia:我脑内存很低，吃瓜耗费我的脑内存
Shure的女友:就不可能喜欢纯哥们
Shure's GF: It's impossible to like just buddies.
男嘉宾:就是有没有那种能喜欢一点
Male Guest: Is there someone you can like a bit?
男嘉宾:坏怎么都是哥们
Male Guest: Why are they all just buddies?
男嘉宾:那不坏那不坏
Male Guest: No, not bad, not bad.
Shure的女友:没有一点关系
Shure's GF: It has nothing to do with it.
Katrina: 我要我要
Katrina: I want it, I want it.
Katrina: 喜欢的话我第一眼喜欢就是喜欢
Katrina: If I like it, I like it at first sight.
Nicous: 为什么没带出
Nicous: Why didn't you bring it out?
男嘉宾:那你下次就告诉他你下次就告诉他
Male Guest: Then you should tell him next time, just tell him next time.
男嘉宾:就说你就说
Male Guest: Just say it, just say it.
男嘉宾:我我我喜欢我喜欢的人
Male Guest: I, I, I like the person I like.
Shure: 他一直在放
Shure: He's been playing it.
Shure: 他那个普通朋友是吗
Shure: Is he that ordinary friend?
Shure: 那个全民k歌那软件
Shure: That karaoke app for everyone.
Lucia:啊这个是
Lucia: Ah, is this...
Lucia:刚才谈的那个吗还是其他的
Lucia: Is this the one we talked about just now or another one?
Alice:你是不是卖牙线棒来着
Alice: Are you the one who sells dental floss picks?
Alice:你能给我顺一根吗
Alice: Can you give me one? I feel like something's stuck.
Alice:好像卡东西了
Alice: It seems something's stuck.
刘婷:压线棒不是在你那个
Liu Ting: Aren't the floss picks with you?
Lucia:网网网的问题
Lucia: It's a network problem.
Lucia:可能是你看他一直连接中
Lucia: Maybe, you see, it's always connecting.
刘婷:朋友那吗
Liu Ting: With a friend?
刘婷:忘了
Liu Ting: I forgot.
Lucia:就我
Lucia: Just me.
Alice:哦啊 为什么是她 她拿走了
Alice: Oh, why is it her? She took it.
Lucia:不知道是不是这个地方的问题
Lucia: I don't know if it's this place.
Lucia:还是怎么回事
Lucia: Or something else.
Lucia:反正我的网经常不行啊
Lucia: Anyway, my internet often doesn't work.
Lucia:你那边那可能是我的我还没收到
Lucia: On your side, it might be mine. I haven't received it yet.
Alice:你就不能给我留两根
Alice: Can't you save me two?
女嘉宾:但如果你要发的话得给我先p一下啊
Female Guest: But if you post it, you have to edit it for me first.
Lucia:啊没问题
Lucia: Ah, no problem.
Lucia:你可以P好了发我
Lucia: You can edit it and send it to me.
Lucia:就发你P好的
Lucia: Just send me the edited one.
Alice:咱俩就坐这
Alice: Let's just sit here.
Lucia:我特别的哎呀乘凉
Lucia: I'm just, relaxing here.
女嘉宾:好
Female Guest: Okay.
女嘉宾:那我可以把你现在的p一下
Female Guest: Then can I edit you now?
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
女嘉宾:唉不是我p的也p不出
Female Guest: Hey, but I can't edit it well either.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:对一天一千五
Jake: Yes, fifteen hundred a day.
Lucia:没事放心就是就是
Lucia: Don't worry, it's fine, really.
Lucia:我比如说跟别人合照的话
Lucia: For example, if I take a photo with someone else,
Lucia:就是朋友同一个情况下我才发
Lucia: I only post it if we're friends.
Alice:她家有
Alice: She has it at home.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:那下回到他家拍
Jake: Then next time we'll take pictures at her place.
Lucia:所以就是我的懒主要体现在
Lucia: So, my laziness shows in...
Lucia:就是如果我朋友没P我就不P也不发了就
Lucia: If my friend doesn't edit it, I won't edit or post it either.
女嘉宾:我就哈哈哈错过下次错过
Female Guest: I just laugh it off and miss the next opportunity.
Shure的女友:胶片感
Shure: It has a film feel.
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
女嘉宾:如果我去主动去q这个流程然后
Female Guest: If I actively go through this process...
Lucia:如果我
Lucia: If I...
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
女嘉宾:没关系
Female Guest: It's okay.
刘婷:没有他也是就是这种
Liu Ting: No, he's just like this too.
Jake:那就我呢
Jake: What about me?
Jake:在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Shure的女友:就整个胶片拍出来
Shure: Just shoot the whole thing on film.
Lucia:啥呀 啥呀
Lucia: What? What?
Jake: 她说她家
Jake: She said it's at her place.
Alice:她家
Alice: Her place.
Jake: 她家也有类似这样的院子
Jake: She has a yard like this too.
Alice:他家有这个这样的小院子
Alice: She has a yard like this at her place.
Alice:他不告诉我啊
Alice: She didn't tell me.
Lucia:噢
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:刘婷你天天的
Alice: Liu Ting, you always...
Jake:在哪在哪
Jake: Where is it?
刘婷:在昌平那边昌平
Liu Ting: It's in Changping, Changping.
Jake: 昌平
Jake: Changping.
Alice:昌平
Alice: Changping.
Jake: 噢
Jake: Oh.
Alice:那有大型超市吗
Alice: Are there big supermarkets there?
刘婷:嗯附近吗
Liu Ting: Hmm, nearby?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
刘婷:嗯得开车
Liu Ting: Hmm, you need to drive.
Alice:多多远的车
Alice: How far by car?
Jake: 咱也开车
Jake: We can drive too.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia:哎哎
Lucia: Hey hey
Lucia:怎么突然断电了
Lucia: Why did the power suddenly go out?
女嘉宾:9点半
Female Guest: 9:30
Jake:他 他真讲究
Jake: He, he is really particular.
Jake:九点半
Jake: 9:30
Lucia:才九点半哎
Lucia: It's only 9:30!
Lucia:好过份 至少也要十一点断电吧
Lucia: So unfair, at least cut the power at 11:00.
女嘉宾:可是我发现啊
Female Guest: But I found out
女嘉宾:就是这个
Female Guest: that this
女嘉宾:其实你昌平在哪边
Female Guest: Actually, where is Changping?
刘婷:其实你你就是拍你拍视频
Liu Ting: Actually, you just shoot, when you shoot the video
Lucia:昌平在哪边
Lucia: Where is Changping?
Lucia:顺义是那边 昌平市昌平是市
Alice:那你亮灯的时候不拍
Alice: Then why don't you shoot when the lights are on?
Alice:你这一灯一灭你在这拍啥
Alice: What's the point of shooting when the lights go off?
Lucia:昌平是西边是吧
Lucia: Changping is to the west, right?
刘婷:我刚摆上灯就灭了
Liu Ting: As soon as I set up the light, it went off.
Alice:我刚拍上灯就灭了
Alice: As soon as I started shooting, the light went off.
女嘉宾:对西北边啊
Female Guest: Yes, to the northwest.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia:我在北京的活动轨迹
Lucia: My activity route in Beijing
Lucia:就只有从我们学校那边
Lucia: is just from our school
Lucia:就五道口那里到
Lucia: to Wudaokou.
Alice:你说你是鬼就可以了 你带上我干嘛
Alice: You could just say you're a ghost, why involve me?
Lucia:对大概连线到天安门
Lucia: Yeah, roughly connecting to Tiananmen.
Lucia:就这一条线上
Lucia: Just along this line.
Lucia:然后呢哈哈
Lucia: And then haha
Alice:你把你手机流量调调高呗
Alice: Why don't you increase your phone data limit?
Lucia:也去但是去的很少
Lucia: I do go there but very rarely.
Lucia:然后我实习的时候会去国贸这边
Lucia: And during my internship, I would go to Guomao.
Alice:嗯 有用啊
Alice: Hmm, that's useful.
Lucia:金台西照这里
Lucia: Jintai Xizhao.
Lucia:东边最远我大概就到这
Lucia: The furthest east I've gone is there.
Lucia:然后除了对除了那阵就是打杂的时候
Lucia: And besides that time when I was doing odd jobs.
Lucia:就是来黄泉城的那个
Lucia: When I came to Huangquancheng.
Lucia:就是拍片子打过杂嘛
Lucia: Just doing some odd jobs for filming.
Lucia:然后来过化妆这里
Lucia: And came here for makeup.
Lucia:就基本上咱们这了就来过一次
Lucia: Basically, I've only been here once.
Lucia:然后其他的最远最远我就到国贸
Lucia: And the furthest I've gone is Guomao.
Lucia:对我们进去了
Lucia: Yeah, we're in.
Lucia:但当时还没有正式营业
Lucia: But at that time, it wasn't officially open yet.
Lucia:所以就没有在里面玩过 对
Lucia: So I never got to play inside, yeah.
Lucia:然后
Lucia: And...
Lucia:所以我对北京的很多地方
Lucia: So, for a lot of places in Beijing...
Lucia:其实都不是很熟悉
Lucia: I'm actually not very familiar with them.
Lucia:因为太大了就没去过
Lucia: Because it's so big, I haven't been to many places.
Lucia:对对对我现在就是拖到我
Lucia:上本科的最后一年
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia:对前三年一个就不太 是的
Lucia: So, the first three years were a bit... Yes.
Lucia:就一个课会多一些嘛
Lucia: The coursework was heavier.
Lucia:然后也不是很想出去
Lucia:就学校太大了就很麻烦
Lucia: The campus is so big, it's a hassle.
Lucia:因为我们要骑自行车才能出学校
Lucia: We have to ride bikes to leave the campus.
Lucia:然后
Lucia: And...
Lucia:然后而且那个地铁站离我们校门还远
Lucia: Plus, the subway station is far from our school gate.
Lucia:然后所以就是
Lucia: So, it's just...
Lucia:除非是去实习或者之类中不得不去了
Lucia: Unless it's for an internship or something, I wouldn't go.
Lucia:否则都不会去的
Lucia: Otherwise, I wouldn't go at all.
Lucia:然后我就一直拖到这一年快毕业了
Lucia: So, I kept putting it off until I was about to graduate this year.
Lucia:然后我看好像有一些景点还没去
Lucia: Then I realized there were some spots I hadn't visited yet.
Lucia:我就把景点打卡了一下
Lucia: So, I quickly checked those places out.
Lucia:所以有就好地方不太熟
Lucia: So, I'm not really familiar with the good spots.
女嘉宾:因为你在国贸
Female Guest: Because you're at the International Trade area.
女嘉宾:国贸实习在国贸附近
Female Guest: Interning around the International Trade area.
Lucia:在国贸附近具体哪个楼，我忘记了
Lucia:我忘记了但它就那一片
Lucia: I forgot, but it's in that area.
Lucia:因为因为
Lucia: Because, because...
Lucia:就是其实
Lucia: Actually...
Lucia:比如说招人的公司大部分都在那个
Lucia: Most companies that hire are around there.
女嘉宾:大部分都在那一块嘛
Female Guest: Most of them are in that area, right?
女嘉宾:我记得我看到一些漫画
Female Guest: I remember seeing some comics...
女嘉宾:就是说他到北京
Female Guest: Saying that when he got to Beijing...
女嘉宾:他到国贸易吃饭的时期
Female Guest: And started eating in the International Trade area...
女嘉宾:然后就觉得
Female Guest: He felt like...
女嘉宾:我居然也能是一个在国贸时期的人
Female Guest: "Wow, I can actually be someone who spends time in the International Trade area."
女嘉宾:现在就觉得很高楼大厦
Female Guest: Now, it just feels like tall buildings everywhere.
女嘉宾:就是最代表北京的一些高楼大厦
Female Guest: Those are some of the most iconic skyscrapers in Beijing.
Lucia:噢
Lucia: Oh.
女嘉宾:在那边嘛
Female Guest: Over there.
女嘉宾:就觉得自己还蛮渺小的
Female Guest: I just feel quite small.
女嘉宾:我我之前
Female Guest: I, I used to...
Lucia:他其实给120一天
Lucia: He actually gives 120 a day.
Lucia:对哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, haha.
女嘉宾:就是不用太东北话那个
女嘉宾:东北话那个气味
Lucia:对对对真的是
Lucia: Yes, yes, really.
Alice:你在聊什么
Alice: What are you talking about?
Alice:工作吗啊
Alice: About work?
Lucia:啊我们在说之前实习的时候
Lucia: Ah, we were talking about our previous internship.
女嘉宾:对还有之前在北京有探索过什么
Female Guest: Yeah, and also exploring something in Beijing before.
Alice:你真的好亮
Alice:这个我是不是也很亮
Lucia:是的
女嘉宾:很明显距离一到晚上就是晚上
Female Guest: It's obvious, once it's night, it's really night.
Alice:很明显
男嘉宾:挺好瞎处置
Male Guest: It's fine, just deal with it.
Alice:巨明显
Alice: Extremely obvious.
Alice:脸上长了个星星一样哎
Alice: It's like a star on your face.
Lucia:好酷时尚单品
Lucia: So cool, a fashion statement.
女嘉宾:你们就会观看这个数据集吗
Female Guest: Will you guys watch this dataset?
刘婷:你别听就好了
Alice:把一件炫酷性感的事情
女嘉宾:观看自己的一言一行
Female Guest: Watch your own actions.
女嘉宾:跟太长都懒得看
Alice:描述的像一个发情母猩猩
女嘉宾:看一点就不看了
女嘉宾:但我最近就跟他们聊了
刘婷:OK你不要听就行
Lucia:那我应该会看一下
Lucia: Then I might take a look.
Lucia:有偶像包袱
Lucia: Have some idol baggage.
Nicous: 没事今天我给他搭回去啊
Nicous: No worries, I'll take him back today.
Lucia:哈哈哈不多但有一点
Lucia: Haha, not much but a bit.
Katrina: 反正我是觉得就是来北京
Katrina: Anyway, I think coming to Beijing...
Lucia:对 因为
Lucia: Yeah, because...
女嘉宾:因为你之后等标注完
Female Guest: Because after you finish marking...
Nicous: 今天给他搭回去
Nicous: I'll take him back today.
Alice:我想睡觉 婷
Alice: I want to sleep, Ting.
就可以全局解锁露西亚
You can fully unlock Lucia.
Alice:欧婷哎
Alice: Oh, Ting.
Nicous: 回到100%的草药版
Nicous: Back to 100% herbal version.
女嘉宾:然后露西亚干什么干什么啊
Female Guest: Then what is Lucia doing?
Lucia:啊他就会定位出来
Lucia: Ah, he will locate it.
Alice:没电
Alice: No power.
Lucia:啊好厉害
Lucia: Ah, that's amazing.
女嘉宾:每一段在干什么事啊
Female Guest: What is each segment doing?
Alice:没有充电宝不值钱
Alice: Without a power bank, it's worthless.
Alice:眼镜值钱
Alice: Glasses are valuable.
Jake:你这抗遗忘曲线挺挺挺棒的
Jake: Your anti-forgetting curve is pretty good.
Jake:我靠 越来越稳
Jake: Wow, you're getting steadier.
Jake:哈哈哈抗遗忘曲线你知道吧
Jake: Haha, you know about the anti-forgetting curve, right?
刘婷:你们平常
Liu Ting: You guys usually...
刘婷:你前几天
Liu Ting: A few days ago...
刘婷:你们你们前几天
Liu Ting: A few days ago, you guys...
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
刘婷:录到多晚啊大概
Liu Ting: How late did you record until, roughly?
Shure: 人民教师了
Shure: A people's teacher.
Alice:快12点 有的时候
Alice: Almost midnight, sometimes.
Lucia:哈哈哈这样子
Lucia: Hahaha, like that.
刘婷:那你睡的够晚的呀
Liu Ting: Then you go to bed pretty late.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:是啊
Shure: 什么钱什么钱啊
Shure: What money, what money?
Alice:10点10点都算早了
Alice: 10 o'clock is considered early.
Alice:11点12点
Alice: 11 o'clock, 12 o'clock.
Shure: 刮刮吧
Shure: Scratch it.
Alice:咋了 困了吗
Alice: What's up? Sleepy?
Shure: 你看我能能刮多长就全转过去好不好
Shure: Watch how long I can scratch, and it will all transfer, okay?
Lucia:噢 好神奇
Lucia: Oh, that's amazing.
Lucia:他就会发现我经常在吃东西
Lucia: He will find that I'm always eating.
Lucia:然后在摸鱼
Lucia: And then slacking off.
刘婷:9:30
Liu Ting: 9:30.
Shure: 修硕的路费没了
Shure: Shure's travel expenses are gone.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:还有多少story
Alice: How many more stories?
Shure: 你还想刮我什么
Shure: What else do you want to scratch from me?
Lucia:要建立一些逻辑的联系
Lucia: Need to establish some logical connections.
Katrina: 带他玩吧带他玩吧
Katrina: Take him to play, take him to play.
Shure: 嗯回家还能让你花钱
Shure: Hmm, going home can still make you spend money.
Alice:还有20多个GB
Alice: More than 20 GB left.
Katrina: 就只跟我玩
Katrina: Just play with me only.
Jake:好忙啊
Jake: So busy.
Shure的女友:不是我真觉得在家里住有点不好
Shure: I really think living at home is a bit bad.
Alice:老板呢
Alice: Where's the boss?
Shure的女友:能在外面住的话真的好困
Shure: If you can live outside, it's really tiring.
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Katrina: 但是那个
Katrina: But that...
Jake:这是赚多少钱
Jake: How much are you earning?
Alice:可以可以关了吗
Alice: Can we close it?
Lucia:对 我也会
Lucia: Yes, I would too.
Shure: 我妈感觉就是
Shure: My mom feels like...
Shure: 让你在外面住就是感觉
Shure: Letting you live outside feels like...
Alice:你还有多少story
Alice: How many stories do you have left?
Lucia:我看一眼
Lucia: Let me take a look.
Lucia:我中间好像断了一次
Lucia: I think I lost connection once.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Shure的女友:没有太好客
Shure: Not very hospitable.
Shure: 对对对没有家那种感觉
Shure: Yes, yes, yes, it doesn't feel like home.
Jake:乱写是吧
Jake: Just making stuff up, right?
Alice:感觉有点困了
Alice: I'm feeling a bit sleepy.
男嘉宾:觉得你好看不
Male Guest: Do you think you're good-looking?
Lucia:我竟然还有41G
Lucia: I still have 41G left.
Shure的女友:因为觉得你好看
Shure: Because they think you're good-looking.
Alice:我28
Alice: I have 28.
Shure的女友:对觉得你好看
Shure: Yes, they think you're good-looking.
Alice:紫棠
Alice: Zitang.
Alice:唉 紫棠你今天在这住吗
Alice: Hey, Zitang, are you staying here tonight?
Lucia:那可能是因为我中间断了
Lucia: That might be because I lost connection once.
Alice:你今天在这住吗
Alice: Are you staying here tonight?
Shure: 谢彬竹这个
Shure: Xie Binzhu, this...
Tasha:你相信吗
Tasha: Do you believe it?
Alice:那你 这是不是
Alice: So, this is...
Shure: 这这个话说的
Shure: This, the way you said it...
Jake:啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Alice:你回去不是就很晚了
Alice: If you go back, it will be very late.
Shure: 他谁看你朋友圈谁不知道
Shure: Anyone who sees your Moments knows.
Lucia:那你是不是要回去 因为9.30了
Lucia: Are you going back? Because it's 9:30.
Jake:愿意很多人愿意
Jake: Willing, many people are willing.
Shure的女友:你现在觉得哦OK
Shure: Do you feel okay now?
Tasha:你相信你对华侨文化的了解程度是
Tasha: Do you believe in your understanding of overseas Chinese culture?
Alice:要不然你今天晚上住在这里吧
Alice: How about you stay here tonight?
Shure的女友:哪个男生不喜欢我
Sister: Which guy doesn't like me?
Shure的女友:你可能就是陷入了一些南宁的视角
Sister: You might just be stuck in some Nanning perspective.
Alice:我们女生很多可以住
Alice: We have lots of girls who can stay.
Tasha:非常了解了解一般
Tasha: Very well understood.
Tasha:不了解还是非常不了解
Tasha: Not understood or very not understood?
Alice:对非常不了解
Alice: Yeah, very not understood.
Shure的女友:但是你无所谓怎么样
Sister: But it doesn't matter to you, does it?
Jake:等会等会
Jake: Wait, wait.
Nicous: 确实 我赞成
Nicous: Indeed, I agree.
Jake:受访者对华侨文化不了解
Jake: The interviewee doesn't understand the overseas Chinese culture.
Nicous: 有没有可能有没有可能
Nicous: Is it possible, is it possible?
Tasha:不了解对吧
Tasha: They don't understand, right?
Shure的女友:就当OK我我是最好看的一个
Sister: Just assume okay, I'm the best looking one.
Alice:主要是有点晚了
Alice: Mainly because it's a bit late.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha:非常了解的有 34个
Tasha: There are 34 who understand very well.
Lucia:是的
Lucia: Yes.
Shure的女友:无所谓他们不喜欢我就是他们
Sister: It doesn't matter if they don't like me, it's just them.
Nicous: 有没有可能他
Nicous: Is it possible he...
Tasha:了解的有47%
Tasha: 47% understand.
Shure的女友:他们他们眼睛有问题
Sister: They have vision problems.
Jake:他不应该画饼图吗
Jake: Shouldn't he draw a pie chart?
Shure的女友:无所谓我是这么
Sister: It doesn't matter, I'm just...
Nicous: 有没有可能
Nicous: Is it possible...
Jake:为什么画垂线图
Jake: Why draw a vertical line chart?
Nicous: 有没有很好的啊
Nicous: Is it possible, it's really good?
Jake:就是因为喜欢你
Jake: Just because they like you.
Nicous: 真的喜欢你的
Nicous: They really like you.
Tasha:不知道他呀
Tasha: I don't know him.
Nicous: 这不很正常吗
Nicous: Isn't this normal?
Jake:傻逼对不起对不起对不起对不起
Jake: Idiot, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Katrina: 我我对我自己
Katrina: I, I to myself...
Katrina: 就是我不会容貌就是我不要应该喜欢
Katrina: I won't look, I shouldn't like...
Tasha:他们两个字加起来
Tasha: Put those two words together...
Tasha:有80%的人都很了解华侨文化
Tasha: 80% of people understand overseas Chinese culture.
Shure的女友:不要对你自己这样
Sister: Don't be like that to yourself.
Katrina: 但是我
Katrina: But I...
Shure的女友:你对你自己
Sister: You to yourself...
Tasha:这不是放屁吗
Tasha: Isn't this bullshit?
Shure的女友:你对你自己整个人感觉就是啊OK
Shure's GF: How do you feel about yourself, like, OK?
Jake:哪受众啊
Jake: Who's the audience?
Shure的女友:整个世界都不喜欢我的人
Shure's GF: The whole world doesn't like me.
Jake:受众群在哪
Jake: Where's the target group?
Jake:他们学校
Jake: Their school.
Jack: 坏了开始开始开始
Jack: Oh no, it's starting, starting, starting.
Jake:华侨大学
Jake: Huaqiao University.
Nicous: 这个指导
Nicous: This guidance.
Katrina: 因为我很害怕
Katrina: Because I'm very scared.
男嘉宾:而且你生日都生日
Male Guest: And your birthday, your birthday.
男嘉宾:都不用管人家喜不喜欢你
Male Guest: You don't have to care if people like you or not.
男嘉宾:跟你有什么关系呢
Male Guest: What's that got to do with you?
Jack: 对啊
Jack: Yeah, exactly.
Shure的女友:是啊
Shure's GF: Yes.
Katrina: 所以今天我对
Katrina: So today I am...
Nicous: 所以他就是喜欢你
Nicous: So he just likes you.
Lucia:添加一下还没有加的同学的好友好了
Lucia: Let's add classmates who haven't been added as friends yet.
Shure的女友:他他喜欢就OK啦
Shure's GF: If he likes you, it's OK.
Lucia:哈哈哈我看看是谁
Lucia: Hahaha, let's see who it is.
Shure的女友:就是你你你
Shure's GF: It's you, you, you.
Lucia:我还没加
Lucia: I haven't added yet.
Katrina: 但是当我就是遇到了他喜欢我的时候
Katrina: But when I met someone who liked me...
Lucia:董宇浩同学
Lucia: Classmate Dong Yuhao.
Nicous: 我就会考虑他为什么
Nicous: I would consider why he...
Shure的女友:你喜欢他也无所谓
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter if you like him.
Shure的女友:他喜欢你也无所谓
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter if he likes you.
Shure的女友:就是你做你自己就好了
Shure's GF: Just be yourself.
Lucia:给他发送一下
Lucia: Send it to him.
Shure的女友:他喜不喜欢你就他现在
Shure's GF: Whether he likes you or not, now...
Alice:走吧咱回去吧
Alice: Let's go back.
Nicous: 他现在主要点
Nicous: Now the main point is...
Shure的女友:你不要内耗
Shure's GF: Don't consume yourself.
Nicous: 他的点在于为什么
Nicous: His main point is why...
Katrina: 为什么喜欢我
Katrina: Why does he like me?
Alice:冲冲冲
Alice: Go, go, go.
Nicous: 他的点就在于为什么我们俩在群里
Nicous: His point is why are we both in the group...
Alice:没干
Alice: Didn't do it.
Nicous: 为什么一聊天
Nicous: Why once we chat...
Shure的女友:你多有趣你足够好看
Shure's GF: You're so interesting, you're good-looking enough.
Lucia:这个同学是谁
Lucia: Who is this classmate?
Shure的女友:这还不是一个人喜欢的吗
Shure's GF: Isn't this something everyone likes?
Alice:老板嘞
Alice: Boss!
女嘉宾:哦他是刘帅
Female Guest: Oh, he's Choiszt.
Nicous: 黑点在就是看你朋友圈
Nicous: The dark spot is you checking your social media.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Alice:可以收工吗
Alice: Can we wrap up?
Lucia:啊那这个呢
Lucia: Ah, what about this?
Nicous: 朋友圈有多啊
Nicous: There's a lot on your social media.
Jake:呃我 收工 收工 收工吧
Jake: Uh, let's wrap up, wrap up, wrap up.
Nicous: 放那么多
Nicous: You posted so much.
Lucia:这还有一个同学 啊
Lucia: There's another classmate, ah.
Nicous: 人家一晚上看完直接看
Nicous: They watch it all in one night.
Nicous: 卧槽我
Nicous: Whoa, I...
Jake:收工 收工 收工吧
Jake: Wrap up, wrap up, wrap up.
Shure的女友:Don't worry so you know why
Shure's GF: Don't worry, so you know why.
Lucia:他是候场候场职员
Lucia: He's a backstage staff.
Lucia:后场
Lucia: Backstage.
Alice:嗯 还有20多
Alice: Hmm, there are over 20 more.
Shure的女友:是不是喜欢
Shure's GF: Do you like it?
Jake:行行行
Jake: Okay, okay.
Katrina: 这么这么容易就喜欢一个
Katrina: How can you like someone so easily?
Lucia:back upstage
Lucia: Back upstage.
Shure的女友:even by shows
Shure's GF: Even by shows.
Lucia:OK
Lucia: OK.
Jake:好收工了收工了
Jake: Alright, wrap it up, wrap it up.
Jake:收工
Jake: Wrap up.
Jake:不录了就就雨萱录一下吧
Jake: No more recording, just let Yuxuan record.
Shure的女友:其实其实我也不知道为什么
Shure's GF: Actually, I don't even know why.
Jake:别哈哈哈哈
Jake: Don't, hahaha.
Alice:我要卸妆 哈
Alice: I need to remove my makeup, haha.
Jake:哈收工了收工了
Jake: Haha, wrap it up, wrap it up.
Jake:关机关机关机
Jake: Turn off the camera.
Katrina: 因为我觉得
Katrina: Because I think...
Katrina: 因为我觉得人还是要相处的
Katrina: Because I think people still need to interact.
Katrina: 觉得他是1月份的人
Katrina: I think he's a January person.
Katrina: 所以我就想了解
Katrina: So I want to understand him.
Jake:好嘞关掉关掉关掉你关掉
Jake: Alright, turn it off, turn it off, you turn it off.
Shure的女友:哎sorry
Shure's GF: Hey, sorry.
Nicous: 我我给你讲一个事情
Nicous: I, I need to tell you something.
Nicous: 我给你讲一个
Nicous: Let me tell you something.
Jake:complete
Jake: complete
Jake:等会等会等会
Jake: Wait, wait, wait.